[Music]
Zombies took over your TV screen with
its dancing dead and it's a giggle each
ear leaders the stars of zombies are so
enticing don't you just want to know
more about the cast members watch this
video and tell the end to find out which
of the stars is 21 and can already play
32 instruments that you can't guess who
are you new to the things if you love
the cast of zombies as much as we do
give us a like hit the subscribe button
for more great videos now on to the cast
of zombies real names and ages Bucky
he is the dancing machine stud that made
waves with his performance and zombies
the actor who plays the villain is named
Trevor Tordjman and brought about
comparisons to Zac Efron with his
brilliant portrayal of the Seabrook high
school head cheerleader you may even
recognize Trevor from the hit dance TV
show the next step in which he plays the
lead of James so how old is this hunk of
a pink and white jacket where and man
Trevor was born in 1995 she'll be the
ripe young age of 23 good news ladies
as of February 2018 Trevor is on the
single market but we doubt his recent
popularity will make him single forever
iliza this ball of spunky funky energy
lights at the screen as the green haired
zombie and new student at Seabrook Eliza
played by actress
Kylie Russell is older than she looks
the actress who is also currently making
her own music was born in October 1996
she'll be 22 years old in summer of 2019
she is dad's best friends in the film
and fellow natives zombie towner Halle
herself grew up in sunny California and
has an older sister who is also in the
entertainment industry Chelsey Tavares
is her sister who is in the new thriller
series by black pills entitled tycoon
seems like Kylie is following in her
sister's footsteps
Zedd said is that tall football throwing
hunk of a zombie that I bet you were all
wondering about when the movie air dad
is Addison's unlikely love interest the
actor playing dead is Milo Manheim and
this role is his breakout into Hollywood
and with Walt Disney Studios prior to
landing Zedd on the show Milo hadn't had
much luck in the acting game now he says
he couldn't be more happy or grateful
for the opportunity he's
and given he even calls the cast of
zombies his family aside from zombies
Milo has a passion for cooking and says
he spends much of his time watching
Gordon Ramsay but wait until you find
out his age though milah looks older and
as tall as ever he's actually super
young he was born in the 2000s March
2001 to be exact
Milo will be 18 years old when
descendants three hits our screens the
second youngest of the main casts we
think Milo has a long successful career
ahead of him Zoe Zoe is the youngest
star of the cast by far Zoe is the
younger sister of Zed from zombie town
and dreams of one day being a
cheerleader and having a dog the
talented youngster who bring Zoe to life
is Kingston Foster Kingston was born in
July 2010 and will be celebrating her
ninth birthday by the time the third
movie will be out however her career is
already blossoming with roles opposite
Jason Ritter and an upcoming film called
Emerson Heights for Kingston will play
Emerson Kingston is definitely the
cutest Dombey we've ever seen keep your
eyes peeled for more of this adorable
talented girl
Addison when the movie starts and we see
the angelic face of the lead cheerleader
Addison all we can think is who is this
Disney star the talented MacDonald II
brought Addison to life Addison is the
girl who falls in love with the football
zombies ed mag is another one of the
under-20 darlings on zombies meg was
born in July 2000 which will make her 19
when she'll appear in the third movie
sounds like with all these July babies
there is going to be quite the
celebration she is also known for her
role as Taylor Otto in American
housewife and ash in team tune meg is
also not just another pretty Disney face
she can also speak Japanese and dreams
of visiting Japan one day this bright
gal is known for being extremely
positive and a joy to work with she sure
will do well at Disney Laci peppy
Seabrooke cheerleader Laci finds that
it's dangerous to hang with zombies the
blond-haired blue-eyed ghoul is played
by Canadian actor Emilia McCarthy Emilia
is known for playing Abby Ackerman on
Maxim's shred as well as having roles in
Canada's Hemlock Grove since Dom B was
filmed in Toronto Emilia actually didn't
have to leave
her home province while shooting her
Instagram is full of fun shots of her
and her cast mates it sure looks like
Amelia had a blast working on the film
the budding star was born in the summer
of 1997 which means she'll be 22 years
old upon the release of descendants
three one of her biggest breaks into the
industry was landing the role of Kayla
in David Cronenberg's 2014 dark comedy
film maps to the stars we think this
girl is going to have a shining career
Stacey Stacey is a dancing queen through
and through the production needed a
top-notch dancer for this role and who
better to fill the part than Jasmine
Renee Thomas jasmine was a dancer in the
2016 the Rocky Horror Picture Show
let's do the time-warp again another
crazy good credit this girl has to her
name is the 2015 MuchMusic Video Awards
when she was a backup dancer for Nick
Jonas Jasmine began to get into the
acting world through her incredible
skills and abilities as a dancer so how
old is this athletic dancer well she is
the only descendents cast member that
doesn't have their age displayed the
mystery shall remain unsolved for now
Bonzo
Bonzo is the green haired dude who
doesn't know too much English so
obviously he speaks native zombie
language the handsome cauliflower eater
is played by Canadian James Godfrey who
was born in January 1997 he'll be 22
when we'll finally get to watch
descendants three he was previously in a
Disney Channel original film the swap
however prior to being an actor he had
over 30 jobs including pizza delivery
boy not only did he have heaps of random
work James can also play 32 instruments
seems like the zombie speaking man had
some tricks up his sleeves prior to
booking zombies James said he never
danced well James you sure fooled us
what cast members age did you find the
most shocking leave us a comment below
that's all for the zombies casts real
names and ages thanks for watching and
see you next time
[Music]